leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell as the show
too woke for you
keep your politics out of my life keep
your source material on okay
look for source materials
keep the function of these allegorical
parallels out of my storytelling
what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here
today what are we gonna watch we're
gonna watch falcon winter soldier
episode five
episode five today very very excited
well as you guys know you gotta hit that
like button if you like
any part of this video at all subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified
when our next reaction is up while
you're waiting for blind waves reaction
to go up and i don't know if you've
heard me mentioned this before
maybe you have but i don't know if they
have full length watch alongs where you
sync up with the time code they're over
at our patreon page it's
well worth it trust me better than bed
bath and beyond that's what i
say and over there we cover so many
shows we're at the same tier you get the
uh you know what if at this point you
already know what the deal is thank you
to eric over at nerdy chronic for
editing these reaction highlights for us
you're the best man lastly i want to
thank john for being here oh
thank you for being here john you are
the lamar to my john walker that is an
honor greg thank you ah i just feel so
loved
avenge me here we go here we go
but first but first let's not forget the
smartphone triumphant
wow that's an epic shot yeah we don't
want anyone else to get hurt
they're relishing in that shield man you
got to give me the shield man
you almost got me you don't want to do
this
yeah we do
[Music]
you knew this was coming pete
get your shield back when you fix this
damn door
nice oh
god they're getting hit with the shield
[Laughter]
oh damn oh he's got the shoe
he got it on oh yeah he got his arm why
are you making me do that
oh his arms like glitching
oh hell no oh dude
that's awesome sweep yeah we could have
been a team
every time they showed the shield oh
there you go taking for a ride
oh no
[Applause]
now let's go pretty badass choreography
oh man
oh you piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
he clipped his wings and it looked like
he was about to
repeat his scene outside
hell yeah wow
just like trying to take the glove off
thanos man seriously oh
what did they do exactly yeah like broke
his arm
like this is so painful
oh
damn it takes a lot of work to take this
guy down yeah i am captain america
what a great moment what a great moment
pick the shield up
and yourself yeah oh that's great
you're the new captain america like when
walker's been holding at the point of
the star has been upside down like a
pentagram
hmm good catch hey you got your uh you
got your sleeve back
taurus hey how'd these break
look at that foreshadowing
next time thanks doris for sure
i'm just going to walk out carrying the
shield yeah you know whatever you forgot
the wings
cable oh
we're transitioning dude
dude you start by visiting lamar's
parents
they need to see you and then we can
build who's this
it's the therapist
these boots are not made for walking
yeah
is that yeah it is so you can just call
me val
but don't call me val just keep it in
your head
oh wow you did
the right thing taking the serum
oh yeah by the way don't worry about the
shield
i know you don't have it
[Music]
there's nothing on it
just says watch veep
the statue he got to the statue
and so did bucky bucky's gonna let him
go i warned sam but he didn't listen to
me
he's as stubborn as steve wrote just
before him
james do what needs to be done
i appreciate the advice
but we're gonna do it our own way
god that you said the scores again i
love them
[Music]
i'm in therapy
oh it's it's alright adorable
i took the liberty of crossing off my
name in your book
i hold no grudges for what you thought
you had to do goodbye james
for now yeah it would be prudent to make
yourself
for the time being white wolf fair
enough
how often does it go in a wakanda i know
seem like it'd be too hard i may have
another favor to ask
you
[Music]
i want to join a basketball team can you
teach me how to dunk
[Laughter]
did you know eli does not become a
superhero
in the comments
i want to make sure i fact check
everything before you
talk on the internet about this he gets
old and never avenges anyone
i need to understand
you understand wow yeah this really
reflects on sam
i used to be like you
until i opened my eyes until i saw
men the red tails
fight for this country only to come home
if i had
crosses burned on their lawn but you
were a super soldier like steve you
could have been the next
the next what steve did not put you in
jail
i'm so happy this show's exploring this
yeah they
experimented on me
trying to figure out why the serum
worked
we got to do something leave me dead my
name is buried but the world's different
now
i know people you think i wouldn't be
dead
in a day if you brought me out you won't
believe
jail was my fault because you got that
white man's shield
they erased me
my history they've been doing that for
500 years
pledge allegiance to that my brother
[Applause]
never better black man be captain
america
no self-respecting black man
whatever wanna be
what would it mean for a black man in
this country to hold up the captain
america mantle
just dropping this off
you can sign for it i'll go
he's just white savioring the whole
thing yeah man just swooping
in and taking all this damn political
commentary
i don't always think of it immediately
right-handed
i hope you can find some measure of
peace in that
knowing that the man who's responsible
god is justice
if you ever need me i'm always here for
you
yeah white russell is a freaking
phenomenal actor he's a
pretty great actress he's in his own
show in this episode
somewhere at a vault there's six
episodes about him
oh please if it weren't for me it'd
still be rotting away in that algerian
prison
[Music]
i can give you double this time i
promise you don't regret saying yes
double
this time oh oh
was is she the responsible for the first
mission when we saw
him that truck sounds like it yeah in
this show you know i mean yeah
when sam was yeah flying after him oh
he's kids playing with the shield hell
yeah
oh yes we're getting the scene nice
that damn time
wow that's scary yeah that's pov when
steve told me what he was planning i
don't think either of us really
understood what it felt like for
the black men to be handed the shield
are you an apology
oh wow
closest thing i've got left to a family
so when you retired it it
made me feel like i had nothing left oh
wow
i love how they're just playing like
this yeah playing frisbee and talking
i'm making amends you weren't amending
you were avenging
you stopping all the wrongdoers you
enabled as a winter soldier because you
thought it would bring you closure
i'm sure there's at least one person in
that book
who needs closure about something and
you're there oh
no no star wars one
save one life good talk
it was using that va knowledge
yeah man groups
you call me when you have a lead and
i'll be there dude yes
this was an amazing scene yeah
hell yeah that's probably my favorite
scene yeah this whole
this is great
[Music]
each out to carve his own path
oh no
i am in love with this
this is so good
yeah gotta get that coordination
god that shoot comes flying back the way
they capture that
just one shot they should make his sweat
all orange and have like a gatorade
commercial the kids are on his left
they're on his left
oh cool
that is not anthony mack
that's fine still a guy can do a great
stunt
what are we doing here i got some help
to even out the odds
sam screwed him out of a small car oh so
she did it she's working with the flag
smashers flag smashing
yeah sharing cars working with the flag
smashers damn
whoa it's like that improv city youtube
channel
[Laughter]
what's sufficient they can't stay with
flagsmasher
yeah that's the new hail hydra for this
show
it's gonna turn into that run the jewels
music video
picture this
oh is this gonna be a new suit oh i
think it might be
maybe it's the wings but in captain
america colors
oh no no no
no what a patient
episode yeah starts off with a
with a bang and then we really slow it
down
to change heal reflect
contemplate decide consider your history
sharon carter man she's the power broker
i think there's a post credit scene
there might be a post-credits scene
oh no
is he building one is he building his
own shield
it's like iron man yeah i don't know so
i thought it right away
yeah yeah he's putting together a shield
oh wow
oh no
no dude no
i'm not done yet i'm captain america
all right well john
jonathan that's me walker that is you oh
no i
am captain america john walker he's
making
okay well the the captain america
shields may have adamantium
that shield's gotta be made out of boxes
this junk metal yeah yeah it's made out
of the same stuff the iron giant was
eating before
i was doing a reference iron man one uh
i was just doing lots of scraps
tony stark was able to build this in a
cave with a bunch of scraps
and now with the camera shutter street
you won't be able to see that come out
of my mouth
yeah that's like a saving private ryan
action scene but
spit a lot of spit milestones yeah dude
totally
so yeah it's mass steel probably that
that shield is won't be as effective as
his
good old captain america shield but
it'll be personal
personal for the guy yeah uh this was my
favorite
sam anything this is my favorite episode
so far i think
this is a pretty great one yeah it's a
pretty damn great one but yeah as far as
like the characters especially for
sam wilson like this to me was
yeah my new cap's in america
yeah man i could see my new cap right
there him really
like traversing the great like it's been
interesting to watch this series grow
especially with the themes the very
first episode brings up about him taking
on the shield him giving up the shield
why did you give up the shield why did
you skirt responsibility
and even just the things that sam has
learned and
in this episode in particular but over
the course of this series like you
really do
see a more sort of world weary person
in there now and especially as he is
like training
with the shield at the end like he he
came across different to me and his body
language and stuff like that like it
really does feel like he is kind of
cresting out of falcon into captain
america
well this episode also really tied it
together with isaiah bradley
showing a big part of why sam didn't
want to take up the shield he had his
hesitations there were
feelings of lack of self-worth that
seemed to be dealing with however
there was that element i think a scene
that has been
criticized was the scene where sam and
bucky were from before they meet isaiah
bradley or no right after right after
where the cops
were coming over like it felt like
forced and shoved into here and the way
it was done whether you feel that way or
not i think the context of that scene is
what's important
because the world that they live in even
in the marvel cinematic universe world
post blip racism is still a very
prevalent thing racism is still the very
real thing that exists in this world
and forgive me for not remembering
correctly i don't really recall
anything with sam wilson in the movies
dealing with racism like his character
having to deal with being a black man in
this world to have this scene with
isaiah brown hey you see why he really
cared so much about the isaiah bradley
situation you know more than just
personal matters
immediately it's a [ __ ] up situation
right and then when you go into the
conversations
about it i love that they address both
the debate about it it's not just hey
steve chose you take up the shield
everything that isaiah bradley's talking
about you could see why
so much of that weighed on him as well
like bucky says it flat out
we never me steve and i never even
really thought about what it must have
been like for you a black man to have to
take up the captain america shield
because
i can imagine if you become captain
america there's already a target on your
back
and i can only imagine how much worse it
must be if you are a black man
who has to take up the captain america
shield how many more targets are
suddenly on your back because of that oh
yeah
you know how many more people are going
to take issue with the very fact that
you've ascended this mantle and it's
interesting to watch through a character
like john walker how much is just
thrust at and upon you when something
like that like
it must be a reward in some way like it
must feel like amazing to be chosen for
that but at the same time yeah it's like
if it's hard on a character like walker
imagine all the extra layers that then
would come to a character like sam or
even worse for a character like isaiah
bradley before him because like that
scene is beautiful in a lot of ways
because i think it too
hones in on something i'm in no way an
expert on but i have you know kind of
seen in the conversation around which is
also the generational gap
between people who have been a part of
the struggle for so long and have seen
the parts of it that have not changed
over
so much time and effort but you know the
newer generation is here to kind of pick
up the torch and keep on
uh you know advancing the fight and
whatnot and i like that they
allowed for both sam and isaiah to
kind you know i mean isaiah says his
piece and he tells his story and sam
takes it in
it's still matriculating throughout the
episode as to you know his decision
like they have that conversation with
his sister at the end where she's like
don't let
isaiah bradley get in your head and it's
like it doesn't negate his
experience and his story to say that
that stuff is still horrific but at the
same
time it's like don't let him dismantle
the fight that you know
is the right one you know here and now
being a person of
this time that we're in and so yeah that
level of history like when they're
talking
behind the house and he's like you know
the tuskegee airmen they fought for this
country they came back only to have
crosses burn on their lawns and for sam
to be like i
i understand that part of it but it's
for you being like the super
human like why couldn't you and like
that harkens back to the first part of
this show where sam you know is having
all this trouble
despite the fact that he's an adventure
and he's done all this service to the
world
uh and so to see those echoes you know
in a lesser extent
now but still effective you know
and really you know brought to harsh
light through isaiah bradley's story was
like really striking yeah
absolutely it was very striking because
that is a bradley hey
first off let's just take a step back
isaiah bradley who's the actor that
plays him carl lumley amazing monologue
oh yeah great delivery you've you can
see that actor clearly created the
memories
everything he's talking about he's
reliving it in his own head yeah and he
could feel the memories
on display just in everything about his
delivery from his tonality of his voice
the expressions that he has the love
lost it's like he's doing the whole
isaiah bradley origin tale and this
this beautifully delivered monologue uh
and we don't need to cut to anything
yeah i was like are we gonna cut to
stuff and it was i thought it's more
powerful to not cut to stuff
and to actually work off of the
reactions that sam wilson has given him
during the conversation and the very
minimal dialogue you know there's a big
part of acting of
like i think of having that good
listening face a big part of acting is
listening and reacting
and i think he actually has a great
listening expression like he's
really hearing the other actors and
though his delivery
is based off of listening taking it in
and letting the dialogue come out that
way you can just feel that in the way
how he does all of his lines
but yeah with isaiah bradley's monologue
hey yeah i like what you brought up
about the generational gap thing it's
absolutely true and i think
applicable in this conversation you know
but there's also the more extreme
sides of things of the time in which
isaiah bradley was here
saving his own brothers in war and then
being persecuted for doing the right
thing
and then being enslaved for 30 years and
then losing the love of his life
never getting a chance to connect with
her her thinking like he had
the opposite route of steve rogers
yeah yeah and in doing like what you
think is right at all costs
he learned it doesn't work out well for
everybody you know i could just see
someone coming in here being like yeah
but how did we know any of that was
because of his rate
yeah what is that this is not actually
race identity politics
is someone coming in there and saying
that crap
flashbacks waiting to be released about
how he was a terrible
guy where's the receipts you know
where's here you just hear
those people coming in there yeah but
you know but it's there it's there it's
absolutely there and
uh and it's here to hark into real
history too
100 uh and i love that grounded like
gritty approach at this
show that's why i'm glad we didn't cut
away yeah because it makes it feel more
real
instead of getting caught up in serums
and all that yeah
yeah well and even just the way they
were shooting a lot of that stuff like
they really emphasized
the glass in this episode because
there's that one shot where you're
looking up and you see
the shield in the case and it's like you
can feel the room and the intimacy of
that like even just in the way they
captured it like this was really
alive despite how you know this isn't
like necessarily the highest paced or
most
rollicking episodes it's the most
intimate episode in a lot of ways and
yes so much of that
felt so tangible and so plugged in due
to how they
chose to actually capture everything i
think how the show captures perspective
is always wonderfully
beautiful had to do with john walker in
the beginning even down to how they
capture the freaking
shield when sam is training like the way
they catch the shield the entire time
every time there was those locked off
shots from behind or when it's like
over his shoulder they don't do like pov
shots but but it feels like you're in
the
it's still pov bouncing backwards yeah
it has to dodge it it's like feel the
velocity
it's scary like especially because
you're aware he's just a human he
doesn't have any serum he doesn't have
any super soldier abilities he's more in
common with john walker than any of his
associates right
technically speaking yeah i thought the
the direction of it was uh so powerful
every
step of the way would sam you know like
him having to make
i love the speech that he gives to bucky
hey you get with bucky i was really
moved and
very touched by how bucky was talking
about why it hurt him so much when he
gave up the shield
the conversation that they couldn't have
when they were having the staring
contest with the therapist
they had that conversation here they had
the what is this really all about from
both sides
yeah for him to talk about how like when
you give up that shield i felt like a
friend left me like he's
having such a difficult time adjusting
to the world and creating connections
that
his heart is still connected to these
nostalgic elements like this
book uh the shield but there's no person
there anymore
it's just items it's nostalgic items and
memories associated with it
that's where his love is where he has a
hard time just connecting
with the people around him you know i
love that line about he's not amending
he's avenging
because that's kind of all he knows what
to do you know
so him having to learn how to just like
having that line of it doesn't matter
what steve thinks
in a way sam is giving this advice to
bucky but he's also kind of saying
for himself yeah he has to choose as
well because i think
to me it didn't feel like he really made
the full decision
sam yeah to take up the mantle until the
final moments when he opens up
uh what i'm assuming is his new suit
yeah i'm assuming it's probably captain
america suit with some falcons wings on
it
right yes yeah it's got to be or just a
new suit for the shield right yeah
that's when i think he's making the
decision fully but i think even then
when he's toying around playing with the
shield
setting up the pads and all that jazz
going on the runs like he's still
building himself up to
like is this the path is this yeah but
then when it comes time to okay black
smashers are here
i'll take it from here boom that's
that's here where he fully arcs
yeah and then next episode shows up
it just kills all the flags yeah justice
violently
oh man it really is harder i don't even
need it
it really is hard to keep your cool in
these situations
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh everyone's got me on tape i say
everybody shows up
i tell you what did i tell you
oh yes ruin all the goodwill they
created in the first five episodes
yeah book uh buck i love sebastian
stan's
support like he played supporting in
that role and and like he has great
listening moments too and i love the
newly established chemistry between the
two i constantly if i give a criticism
on an
episode of a show i do always clarify
with but we got a way how
a whole season wraps up these days
usually you gotta judge television now
by a season not by
episode installments solely especially
for shows like this and uh the thing
that we've been missing about bringing
it back to sam and bucky i'm like oh
damn they brought
all that stuff oh all salmon bucky right
here
their established connection bucky
getting a taste of his lifestyle and his
community
uh was just so grand yeah well i mean
this episode kind of had everything i
wanted because like you know i've
enjoyed everything they've been working
with and
building up into this point but this one
was such a satisfying episode in terms
of character where it is like we're
going back to sam's roots
especially we touch a little bit back
onto bucky's roots with the talk
they have about making amends and
whatnot we know that we'll probably see
that happen
in the next episode like his sisters
back were doing that like i loved when
they brought the community together
to help restore the ship the boat it's
like
a moment where his clout and his
position finally pays off and stuff like
that and it's
well he wasn't even really relying on
the falcon cloud he wasn't relying on
the family history just like yeah
just like parents yeah the community and
yeah like to bring it back to all that
and to really ground this episode in
character before we
you know go and pop off and do the big
world saving stakes and all that like it
really did feel like it
homed back in for a minute it's like the
calm before the storm
yeah yeah yeah but it really had like
this aspect that felt like it was
at least for sam and bucky it felt
restorative in a lot of ways oh great
way to put it yeah yeah
restore the bucky and sam versus the
store the bookies sam
versus
does he have the means to do that maybe
i mean if anyone does probably he
probably knows how to do it but then
yeah the zemo moment yeah
that played out almost i mean i didn't
expect the dorm elijah to show up
but that makes the most sense but yeah i
was like looking back yeah he lets him
go in that moment right it's part of his
arc
so that wasn't a surprise it's still a
really well executed moment still a
beautifully done moment you know
like that just means there's gonna be
more zemo yeah man i mean the last
time we saw thunderbolt ross was at
not was tony stark's widow tony stark's
funeral but
but it was in civil war at the raft
right yeah i think it was
anyway and he's just been there this
whole he just never leaves i'm waiting
for the waiting for
serum damn banner and
so what do i not like wait here until
they all come to me
it's gonna happen i think they're
building up thunderbolts it's gonna
happen
it looks like what they're building up
yeah that would put the perfect
opportunities
uh you know seeds are laid true words
sentence
this just made some kind of sense you
can figure it out john
walker oh what a powerfully written
character he is so grip he has this like
constant disgust
like disdain every time he's just
communicating
you know like this fed up he's just been
pushed
in his way like i love it like when he
when he is in the hearing like you could
tell like that is
everything this character has wanted to
say since the very first episode
practically
because you see like i feel like his
character is a great window
into a person who also has to
you know who has to carry such a big
mantle because whenever you check back
in on
john walker when he's not in a situation
they really do
at least for me manage to pull you into
that character just on a human level
where it's like even if i'm not
with him i can super sympathize
in a lot like the scene where he goes to
talk to lamar's family was a great scene
and it reminded me of like
yeah the core essence of who this guy
could have been as
as a good person but now it seems like
yeah this
job that was given to him this task that
was presented him
was just too much yeah yeah it seems all
consuming
and there are certain roles that people
get to play in in life not that
you know it's exactly the same but you
know like when people rise
or are chosen for that level of power
and responsibility
it can be crushing it's interesting
the tragedy you know interesting to have
that scene when isaiah bradley
before where he's talking with sam about
like people been chasing that white hope
ever since steve got that serum
captain america shield and all that and
then cut to
lamar's family and they they start
talking with john walker about like oh
when you got the captain america man oh
honey you got the show like he was so
proud he was so proud yeah yeah yeah he
called yesterday
all he could talk about was that there's
more nuance to that because of the
it's not just what isaiah brown was
talking about it's because of the
relationship and the connection that
uh lamar and walker have with each other
i think it's so nuanced and i and i
think
the the revealing aspects of his
performance do
showcase yeah the serum reveal like what
you just said how
these are things that he's always
thought and wanted to say and the serum
is what's
revealing his true self that's what's
coming out of him yeah that's why it was
important
abraham erskine chose someone with a
damn good heart
but i love everything y russell does
easily
yeah i'm a tad concerned i am a tad
concerned like it didn't do it here i'm
worried that we're going to pop in the
next episode and lose a lot of that
nuance
i hope not but i can see you're right
you can see a person where they just go
screw it i'm bad i don't want him to
come back because he has some kind of
monstrosity
like the thing that's compelling about
that hearing scene is is like
even though we as the audience can see
what decisions he made
and it's even do you still feel like
he's getting [ __ ] over youtube even
though it's the right thing to do you're
like but damn they take
no responsibility yeah and it's the
thing of when they i thought it was
great when they were cutting in on the
i forget the grc like conference before
they have the vote where nothing is
quite live yet and they're all talking
amongst themselves and they're like you
know we got
we gotta think about how the optics of
this are and what it looks like to
everyone on the outside and then julia
louis dreyfus is that thing about like
these suits like all they have they're
they're big money issues to deal with
and you really do feel that in that
scene of like
it's hard because i'm sure governing and
and
anything to do with geopolitics is hard
and and nuanced and difficult but at the
same time it seems like yeah you've
completely
hung this dude out to dry and not
accepted
any of your party and so in that moment
yeah
you do i felt for john walker
in the sense that it's like yeah i don't
think he should be captain america i
don't think he should be able to keep
the shield but at the same time
they're completely cold about it and
they seem not to
acknowledge again the the human stuff
that is so crucial to all these
scenarios see i think this show can play
it fair a lot of the time and take the
opportunity to talk about perspectives
on things
it would be very easy to write
john walker out to be someone who's this
like
hardcore conservative yeah
he's like a rah-rah yeah and then like
do some type of white supremacy
commentary to complement
the isaiah bradley character's uh
beliefs and point of views and what he's
had like
it could have been very easy to go that
path but they don't do that yeah i know
some people have taken to twitter and
have
concluded that that's the case with john
walker i don't think that's the case at
all and there might be some certain
privileges that have been dealt his way
however he's he's definitely not a
racist character
you can apply it you don't really get
into his beliefs about people and so you
don't really get into that of people's
society with his beliefs and stuff
yeah i think some people have been
projecting that and maybe because also
with the comics of what john walker has
expressed about his thoughts and point
of views
yeah that's probably been applied here
too but it's not present in the show
itself so i think it's interesting to
end
episode four and go that's a terrible
thing steve rogers never would have done
that this is why you can't be captain
america i get it like yeah you were
pushed i understand why you were pushed
that far same time
there's there's a responsibility you got
up holding your murder man in cold blood
when you didn't have to kill him and
then you go to the next episode and be
like damn you guys didn't even give him
a shot
you guys never cared if you cared about
it yeah yeah
so you read it like you're gonna pass
all your fault you're gonna be
dishonorably discharged you're gonna
have no life after this yeah
you've got nothing from us thanks bye
yeah they gave him nothing left him
hanging dry
and it broke my heart all the more when
he has to talk to lamar's family and
basically tells a gigantic white lie
oh yeah the guy got his judge like not
even
that like i feel like if that was
actually true
maybe things would be a little different
for children right now but like it's
it's very tragic yeah i mean yeah the
fight was cool that's a lot
maybe fight the fight was really well
choreographed too
i love the implementation of what
they've done with falcon's wings in the
fight scenes
one of my favorite moments of that when
he's trying to he's locked onto the
shield and then
walker's feet are up in the air like the
wire effects on how they're doing
you know what i'm talking about i don't
know how to explain that but
yeah when that that whole sequence i
thought was really well choreographed
and then working together and
yeah i love that one where bucky like
drops the shield right next to him
well they make the shield such a menace
like throughout the episode they gave it
such
presence but especially then when it
still got the blood all over it like the
way they shot that man like
well they've brought this whole ep this
episode in particular was brought back
to what the first episode talked about
which is about you know what does the
shield mean what is the symbolism behind
it
and at the end of the day this with the
symbols stem from who the people are
you know behind it that's the symbolic
things like the shield can mean
a lot of different things but it really
depends on who's holding the shield yeah
and what they do with the shield
that's how symbol is applied yeah that's
when they're doing like the montage of
salmon and everything i was i was like
dan
my cat he walks away from bucky when
they're like having their little buddy
cop banter like we're not partners
whatever
but he's walking we're like oh [ __ ] he
he captain america
yeah he's arkham he's ours we loved it
and yeah shannon carter
a little bad working with the flag
smashers
bacharach batroc leaper he's like oh i
won't
want to get better falcons i mean yeah i
want the first revenge
okay cool that's cool and then we got
julia louie
right right here it goes and julie lou
driver two she played let's look at that
328 a.m cut to 45 minutes later we've
read all the comics about valentina
allegra de la fontaine uh my favorite
character now i'm so excited to watch
her do
various martial arts and be involved in
covert operations of of sorts
femme fatale character of sorts was once
nick fury's girlfriend
oh hey and maybe even gonna show up in
the in the black widow movie
who knows probably he's gonna start
femme force yeah oh
look out getting too woke two two two
woke one step at a time every 10 years
whoa you're gonna have two prominent
female characters
on dubious sides of the law in one show
what are we doing here marvel quit
pushing your identity politics down my
throat
by basing your movies off of the source
material
[Laughter]
i'm just excited for serious on sony it
makes a golden globe
like she's such a talented actress oh
yeah i mean she was great in that scene
and i was a little distracted because
i'm like it's truly louis dreyfus i'm so
used to seeing her do comedy you know
like i was so
enveloped in that aspect of it but she
wasn't doing like a super serious take
you know yeah she's bringing her julia
louis dreyfus humorous chops
playing the kind of role you hire
somebody we know for comedy to stretch
out it yeah you know
but seem like she's a setup for
something yeah
maybe she's the power broker that was
part of what pulled me out of
her scene too was it was like i feel
like you're here to
set up a bigger world thing for
something that's going to happen in a
different marvel property
x-men mephisto i mean
she could be linked to secret invasion
be
like what we quickly read was how at one
point you know uh
sprawls wanted her to spy on nick fury
for info
that was right scroll impersonated uh
her hers
in person oh god i can't wait for those
fans there's going to be theory videos
she's probably the scroll she's a scroll
scroll everything leading up to secret
invasions there's going to be
so many scrolls seriously everyone's
none of this is all taking place off of
earth that post-credits scene in
spider-man
far from home i mean everyone's a strong
and everything
everyone's a stroller mephisto so and
it's all in the multiverse so really
there's
infinite versions of all of them and
carly seems like she's just morphed into
bad
she's just bad now i'm like what the
hell like it was her new one i mean she
had the nuance moment in like what is
going to take to be citizens of the
planet but that final moment with the
working with the criminals i'm like you
just
seem like like that one that one
charming long-haired guy
who's always there to be like what are
you doing colleen i don't care again
well you just always call in and she's
like yeah but
this is how they do things
that's that's a great reenactment well
that's
i love carly scenes i love carly but
then her scenes are like well you didn't
call it oh
what do we that is perhaps one thing
that does not
benefit so much from just yeah so much
focus goes to other things in this
episode that yeah when you
check in with the flag smashers it does
feel a little bit like okay here's a
couple plot beats and we'll see you next
episode
uh so yeah i i i wonder how much there
is to that theory uh that like eric boss
has brought up and stuff about
them having to take out or
recontextualize a certain amount of the
flag smasher plot due to real world
events
so i wonder if it maybe suffers because
of that because yeah like we've
we've dealt with versions of that in the
past of them going to these extreme
efforts
obviously she and sam literally talk
about it and now it seems like the even
more elevated version of that it's in
new york holy crap but also yeah it's
like
okay well you're you're in villain mode
now and that's kind of all the time we
have
for you yeah whereas yeah like the only
complaint maybe is like maybe this show
could have been seven episodes and we
could have gotten a little bit more with
these flag smashers to really
make the argument that much harder
basically well i feel like we're carly
specifically so everyone's not
everyone's like saying we gotta kill
carly no one's even saying we gotta kill
the flag smashers
and then no more will grow back because
they're not hydra exactly
yes yes yes yes so carly
i think with the what's happening here
is falcon is the only one who's like
no should we we gotta get through to her
and everyone's like nah she gotta die
even bucky's even in conflict like hey
zemo zemo's saying you know
killer he's the expert on super super
people so yeah
so i think part of the growth and
demonstration of because it's like you
think of captain i'm like captain
america he would do everything he can
he's like naruto or doctor if you guys
have seen the rudolph or doctor who or
the doctor
yeah like if there's an opportunity to
save a life
yeah even if it's to change someone or
to give someone the chance to make a
better choice they will do whatever they
can
first to make sure that that's part of
like the captain america
values so i think that's gonna be part
of the demonstration
is that's gonna be ten oh man that's how
you say about it before i get a bunch of
crap
nerudo naruto naruto you're a fan of
that nardo
i'm a fan of that naruto i love naruto
and rick lee
yeah when naruto and midoriya fight each
other dude
dude all you need then is uh all you
need is one is gone
yeah you gotta get gone dude throw throw
light yoga me in there why not
who cares dude let's get some gundams in
there let's get like a dragon ball or
two
there's been one character been trying
to name this whole time this is not
coming in my mind it's like the other
show that's just as big as
oh it's avatar there you go dang
we did it this was the party that we're
waiting for
all right guys well we're done for today
it's a good ass episode i hope some of
you stayed around for this part of the
conversation
we've talked a little while leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
notification bell as the show too woke
for you
keep your politics out of my life keep
your source material
on i'm calling for source materials
keep the function of these allegorical
parallels out of my
storytelling all right i want nothing
of enrichment or probing challenging
themes
leave it leave them make me feel good
and affirm what i already think
um patron of the day shout and
daniel gallacher daniel don't do it man
don't take the super soldier serum i
know somebody spilled a few vials
in the scotland where you work
it's a shout out for you buddy you know
where this was headed
but we're gonna we're gonna zoom into
the pharmacy and we're gonna reveal that
this pharmacy is not just any scottish
pharmacy all right this
place is old to dark secrets you
couldn't
imagine all right we're talking
experiments on people we're talking
about
international secrets being traded
and i know it all falls on you daniel
you got to get the prescriptions right
you gotta provide good customer service
you gotta be friendly but also efficient
and the whole world's on your back well
you know what
i believe in you and i wanna be your
lamar
so daniel gallacher milo oh [ __ ]
i can be both your okay i'll be your
lamar and i'll be your bucky because
that's a
much lower impact commitment
theoretically
this whole episode bucky was like yeah
if you figure out anything about carly
just call me i'm leaving
so like i have this i love you buddy
don't take the syrup
you